[Music]
tyler is in abilene texas hey tyler how
are you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well uh
me and my wife are new to you we got
married in june congratulations
from the ground running we
we knew debt was a bad idea
uh she came into the marriage debt free
i did not by a long stretch
so he as soon as we got married get back
to the honeymoon started attacking debt
and working together to pay it off um we
really haven't argued about money at all
until last night so
our tie breaker so oh oh boy okay
so what what is the argument about this
is great i'll get my whistle out my
little strike my little striped i need a
flag too i could throw a flag on him
yeah that's it yeah all right go tyler
what's the argument
all right so i'm a youth pastor
and we were talking about
once we get out of baby step two about
investing
and my cpa has talked to me a little bit
about possibly filing an exemption for
social security taxes
my wife is concerned uh about doing that
in case you know the what-ifs could
happen if i
injured and couldn't work or or whatever
or disability wouldn't be wouldn't be a
factor
in my mind behind it being a real uh
numbers-minded person
say well we can make a lot more in
investing that we're getting out of debt
quicker if we opted out of the social
security
i don't know what you would
advise in that uh either direction or
neither at all
darn darn darn
i don't get to blow my whistle
you're both right yeah
so let me walk you through what how we
handle this okay um yes i believe
pastors
should opt out of social security
uh in order to do that you have to sign
a document that it says you're a
conscientious objector that only has a
religious basis
you do not believe
in the social security
system and it's only for your pastoral
income by the way if you have another
income that income subject social
security it's only for your pastoral
income now i could sign that with good
conscience because i believe the bible
teaches us to be good managers good
stewards of money and giving money to
the social security system is by
definition not being a good steward
and so that's not a joke that's just a
math i mean that's a morality fact as
far as i'm concerned and so you're not
being a good manager if you give the
government money and you didn't have to
so i can i could in good conscience be a
conscientious objector i don't have that
option because i'm not a pastor so
yes i would opt out and yes you're right
you would make more money by investing
that money putting it in a fruit jar you
would end up with more
than giving it to them it has a negative
rate of return
the social security system does on
average plus when you die they keep the
money you put in and use it for the
other people okay versus if you put it
in a fruit jar when you die if your
relatives can find it you'd be okay they
would have it get the metal detector out
in the backyard like yeah we'll be at my
place right because i bury coffee cans
everybody knows that not but anyway so
um
now your wife is also correct the social
security system does three things that
you would be unwise to
step away from the social security
system without covering for those three
things
one
is disability
uh and you would not be getting ssi or
social security disability if you became
disabled so you need to buy long-term
disability insurance before you opt out
oh you need to do that whether you opt
out or not because the social security
disability is not enough to live on
so everyone needs long-term disability
insurance anyway okay
the second thing is you will not be
receiving disability at our social
security at retirement
so uh you will need to save for
retirement oh wait a minute you need to
do that anyway because we've already
covered they suck the rate of return the
money you're going to get at retirement
is awful you'll be eating alpo
so you need to have a retirement account
but not doing a retirement account not
doing this social security and not
having a disability account and then you
retire broke or you get disabled and no
policy your wife is right that would be
really dumb
okay and the third one is and it's not
applicable yet but if you have children
and you die your children get paid
social security until they reach 18
on your behalf and you would need to buy
life insurance to make sure your family
is taken care of in the event of you
dying before you're rich oh wait you
need to do that anyway
because the social security coming to
your kids is not going to be enough and
so i could consciously conscientiously
object and step out but you got to cover
disability death and retirement but you
got to do that
anyway
i'm thinking about being a pastor dave
all of a sudden
part time of course dave i'm not leaving
oh
this is the ramsey show